nashville and the country music world
are still buzzing about the surprise
ending of the acms
you know what let's check in with rachel
smith because she is still right there
in the middle of it all
i am kev it was an awesome show we
talked to all the big winners and what a
history making night for carrie
underwood
how does it feel holding that statue
right now it feels great
we have a tie keith what is happening
right now
20 20 man i like to share
i like to share with people yeah tied
for entertainer of the year with
harry underwood i know my heart is is
racing so hard right now
of course it's 20 20. nothing's gonna be
like normal
good bad tide whatever but honey you've
got that statue
and you've worked hard to prove it thank
you thank you so much
unfortunately carrie forgot to thank her
hubby and science
but she had a lot to do performing and
quick changing twice
with some diy style standing in your
cardigan taylor swift went low-key chic
doing her own hair and makeup when
stefani fringed it up for her duet with
winter blake
the couple green screened in from l.a
voila
welcome back to the bluebird cafe
everybody conveniently avoiding the same
nashville venue as his ex the acm's
all-time most decorated winner miranda
lambert
but was gwen shading her ex she posted
this photoshopped pic
of her and blake the original was with
gavin rossdale
fans freaked when tweeting gavin is
literally out of the picture
with 17 songs about drinking
[Music]
morris after like having a baby and not
doing anything for six months this is a
lot of adrenaline oh this is so crazy
what are you gonna tell us are you
resting your hand on your butt
oh my gosh all the feels girl i am just
so overwhelmed and so thankful
dan and shay i'm scrambled right now so
i'm like
trying to process it all as a presenter
you know you're looking and wanting to
feed off of the crowd but
no crowd fading off at this time no they
say imagine the audience is naked so
what i did tonight is
that i imagine all the seats were
unupholstered
and that helped me uh to get through it